pas d
[Musique]
philippe lellouche nous a rejoint cochet
c'est parti pour nous chanter you are
the one for me for me formidable avec
les lieux divers domaines hormis for me
formidable
est ce que vous savez qu elle est
l'invitée café les deux derniers salir
l'année dernière le record d'audience et
l'année d'avant le record d'audience
vous savez qui c'était toute l'équipe de
top gear est avec nous ce soir
franchement joli ctif qui veut faire une
course contre isabelle rouge et richard
acadienne
et oiseaux c'est ce que je t'ai dit par
la coupure pub toi tu es un géo qui a
réussi des cas des conneries là mais tu
es content les gens ne savent pas qu par
la pub qui chante tu danses hormis
sahimi six équipes saxo franchement vu
je voudrais le dire
est-ce que je peux m'engager 2t
animateur pour jouer au théâtre bien sûr
tous les soirs à la madeleine à partir
de la rentrée
est ce que vous êtes libre non je le
fais tu dirais que là tout de suite non
sans lever la proposition aux deux
les deux me disent s'ils veulent ou
s'ils veulent pas c'est non alors je
peux tout vous dire après allez-y fille
voudrait proposer à camille combal enora
malagré j'ai joué au théâtre à partir du
mois de septembre toute la pluie tombe
sur moi sacha distel je fais comme si je
ne la sentais pas je ne marche pas car
toute la pluie tombe sur moi comme ça
sur moi tant à des femmes
je suis là bas si peu
d'offrir aux cadeaux
là
j'ai trois parts de galette il y en a
donc une avec du chocolat il y en a une
je vous le dis avec du fromage très très
fort mois les très bonnes c'est du
chocolat reis et cyril moi c'est du vrai
moitié du chocolat non c'est non bush je
crois que c'est un prix un problème ah
bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais pas moi
[Musique]